Salut ! Nous sommes donc dimanche matin.
Et hier soir c'était l'anniversaire de Pierre Croce !
Ses 30 ans, ainsi que la fête pour son million d'abonnés.
Autant vous dire qu'on n'est pas rentré très tôt ...
Et que ce petit levé ce matin pour faire la vidéo a été le plus dur des levés de l'année.
Mais rassurez vous j'avais écris quand même le contenu de la vidéo hier
Donc j'ai plus qu'à la tourner, à la monter, à la mettre en ligne pour qu'elle sorte à 11 heures.
Il est quelle heure ?
10h02 ... C'est jouable !
Avec une magnifique vue sur ma tasse montagnarde.
Cette semaine on a un petit peu changé le rythme des vidéos pour faire une semaine spéciale sur les micro-expressions.
Il existe 7 micro-expressions principales, majeures et universelles.
Et on les a détaillées toutes une par une cette semaine.
La colère, le dégoût, le mépris, la surprise, la joie, la peur.
Mais ça fait que 6 ça !
C'est pourquoi je vous propose de cloturer cette semaine en vous parlant de la tristesse.
[Générique]
La tristesse est liée à une douleur émotionnelle
que se soit la votre, c'est à dire vous vous êtes triste personnellement de quelque chose
ou qu'elle soit liée à un aspect plus empathique, c'est à dire y'a un événement qui vous affecte
ou la tristesse de quelqu'un d'autre qui vous affecte.
Avant de vous donnez la liste des muscles principaux rentrant en marge dans la micro-expression
Je vous rappelle qu'une micro-expression est une combinaison complète !
C'est une association de plusieurs muscles qui se mettent en marche en même temps.
Un des signes de la tristesse n'est pas forcément un muscle qui se met en marche ou pas
Et c'est quelque chose de dur à expliquer avec les mots.
C'est quand les yeux regardent un peu le lointain, comme si les yeux se perdaient, on dit la personne regarde du vide.
Le regard semble un petit peu ailleurs.
Sinon au niveau des muscles, nous avons la commissure des lèvres,
le coin des lèvres qui descend légerement
Ne vous attendez pas forcément à voir toujours du...
Je pense que ma tête est magnifique.
Comme dans toutes les micro-expressions, c'est plus léger.
L'intérieur des sourcils qui remonte légèrement, un petit peu comme dans la peur
et contrairement à la peur, c'est les paupières supérieures qui vont se baisser un petit peu.
Dans la peur, elles se relèvent.
C'est la seule micro-expression qu'on peut cacher avec plus ou moins de succès
et dans certains cas, il arrive qu'il y ait une petite dilatation des narines.
Oui, des narines. Comme ça, avec des trucs qui coulent... Nan ! Ça c'est dégueulasse !
C'est quand la personne pleure.
J'ai pas trouvé dans mes visionnages récents d'exemple concret à pouvoir
isoler et vous insérer, j'en ai cherché pas mal,
je pense qu'il me faudrait plus de temps, c'est le genre de chose que
je pourrai vous faire plus facilement l'année prochaine quand on sortira du rythme d'une vidéo par jour
mais je pense qu'on peut en voir souvent dans les émissions de télé-réalité. Vu les tensions qui s'y passent,
Les espèces de petites trahisons qu'il y a, les personnes qui sont éliminées ou pas.
Je pense qu'on doit en voir assez régulièrement, des micro-expressions de tristesse.
Vous vous demandez : pourquoi si je pressens qu'il y en a là-dedans, je n'en ai pas cherché.
Et bien excusez-moi de m'être sauvé de quelques heures de visionnage de télé-réalité.
Mais n'hésitez pas, vous pouvez le faire vous si vous voulez.
Voici quand même une illustration très probante avec tous les muscles en fonction.
Ça c'est...vraiment vous avez tout sur cette photo
Il faut également savoir que la peur est souvent précédée ou accompagnée
de signes d'anxiété, de stress. j'en avais déjà parlé dans les trois vidéos que je vous ai faites sur le mensonge.
Ce qui me fait rebondir. Dans les récents commentaires de cette semaine,
Vous m'avez souvent demandé des vidéos sur le mensonge ou sur d'autres sujets..
... Des vidéos qui ont déjà était faites.
Il y a déjà 311 vidéos sur la chaîne au moment où je vous parle.
Pensez à checker dans les playlists. J'ai éssayé de catégoriser.
Il y a souvent la vidéo que vous cherchez déjà
Idem sur les questions sur : "Pourquoi la vidéo elle n'est plus numérotée ?" ou
"Qu'est-ce que tu feras l'année prochaine ?" ou "C'est quoi les musiques que tu utilises ?"
"C'est quoi le t-shirt que tu portes ?" "Quelles sont tes dates de spectacle ?"
En général, vous trouvez la réponse dans la description, tout simplement.
Je vous avoue que c'est très frustrant de lire un commentaire sur des infos que j'ai mis
Dans la description, le jour même. Exprès pour que les gens ne se posent pas la question.
Et, tant qu'on en est à parler de ce sujet.
Dans les vidéos du style la FAQ ou la vidéo spéciale pour les 100 000 abonnés
j'ai répondu à beaucoup de questions que vous me posez régulièrement.
Et je ne re-répond pas à ces questions dans les commentaires puisque j'y ai déjà répondu.
Je préfère privilégier des choses qu'on ne m'a pas déjà demandées.
J'espère vraiment qu'avoir pris le temps chaque jour de la semaine
de parler de micro-expressions, c'était un truc que vous m'avez beaucoup demandé cette année,
j'espère que ça, ça vous aura plu. Ça m'a beaucoup plu de le faire.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ! J'ai hâte qu'on soit la semaine prochaine aussi
pour qu'on refasse des choses différentes. J'ai déjà plein de sujets à vous parler, j'ai des gens à mentaliser.
N'oubliez pas avant de partir de liker cette vidéo, c'est important !  Si vous pensez oublier...
...Et bien n'oubliez pas et faites-le !
Et tant qu'on est sur une vidéo un peu comme ça, un peu blabla : merci à tous ceux qui me suivent !
ponctuellement ou à fond en regardant toutes les vidéos. Merci à ceux qui partagent les vidéos !
Ça c'est grâce à vous que la chaîne comme ça elle peut continuer à se faire connaître.
Merci particulierement à ceux qui sous-titrent les vidéos et qui les rendent accessibles aux malentendants.
Bravo !
Et si vous personnellement vous n'êtes pas encore abonné à la chaîne du Mental vlog, n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner en cliquant ici ou par ici ou sous la vidéo !
Parce que le Mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez-vous demain à 17h. Tchao !
[Générique de fin]